hello everyone after uh pretty slow
round noun of the Tata Steel chess
tournament we have a rather explosive
round ten here we have Gawain Jones with
the white piece is playing against
former world champion Vishwanathan Anand
and Wayne Jones is known for his
aggressive style and he was attacking
and he knows that if he opens the game
with e4 Anand will probably defend with
the Sicilian c5 and he has a special
treat prepared for Anand so let's see
let's see how this surprise goes Jones
opens the game with E 4 and we have c5
by Anand and c3 the the elephant
variation we have Knight to f6 v 5 we
have Knight to d5 and now Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and here would a move like
d4 you're going into the main line
probably see capture Sunday for nd
Bishop to c4 and then the game goes on
probably Knight to be 6 and so on but
here after this Knight to c6 move we see
the immediate Bishop to c4 and this goes
into a variation that it's hard to say
if Jones was prepared for this night to
be 6 Bishop to b3 and now c4 kicking the
bishop back to c2 c2 and here the c4
pawn will be very useful and stopping
White's expansion in the center with d4
but I'm pretty sure Jones was prepared
for all of this as in the opening moves
Jones spent maybe 5 6 minutes minutes
and Anand spend about half an hour so we
have d 6 e captures on d6 and he run and
spent quite a lot of time he decides to
play Queen captures on d6 this is a very
short variation where and we'll prepare
Bishop to g4 and Castle queenside so
it's definitely gonna be an interesting
game as there will be opposite side
castles so we have castles by Jones and
Bishop to g4 now pinning this night and
it's not all that easy to unpin I mean
sure you could go some h3g 4 moves but
with opposite side castles this will be
just too risky
so h3 is on the board Bishop to h5 and
rook to e1 and here R goes for the
queenside castle
we have Bishop to e4 and this Bishop to
b4 move
it doesn't seem like it doesn't seem
like it was necessary Jones does go for
it and we have e six by Anand b3 now
trying to expand on the queenside also
maybe creating an attack of its own but
here we have f5 pushing that Bishop back
to C - and now g6 and with with this
bone structure black doesn't really have
any problems and this Bishop is simply
great on h5 also the Jeep one is
defending it
after g6 was played Bishop to g7 maybe
even h6 will always be always be an idea
so a very nice position for on out here
and we have B captures on c4 and now II
five and this is a probably the critical
moment of the game what a move like d3
you you want to keep an eye on the
Foursquare not allow Anand to expand
further woody for but here
Jones felt like he was really pressured
by on out here the rook is still on a1
the knight is undeveloped the bishop on
c1 is looking pretty useless the bishop
and c2 is fine but all of these pieces
are really really still under starting
squares so he played d4 with the idea
that he wants to open up the game and
and start something here on unplayed it
captures on d4 and what do you play here
for white the problem is you can't
capture here on before if the place C
characters and before you get Bishop
captures on f3 Queen captures and now
Knight captures on d4 attacking the
Queen and the bishop on c2 and after you
defend the bishop you get Bishop to g7
now this Bishop is lined up with the
Queen and the rook and it's simply a
much better position for black all
blacks pieces are very active so after
this he captures on d4 Jones decides to
go for Bishop to g5 attacking the rook
and you do have quite a lot of options
here for black one of the options that
immediately comes to mind is d3 pushing
this pawn further
attacking the bishop on c2 and after you
move the bishop Bishop to b3 you
probably go for something like Bishop to
e7 and continue the game having a very
nice pawn on d3 but a nun goes for a
different light
after this Bishop to g5 move on plays a
very gentlemanlike move Bishop to g7 he
offers the rook on the 8th as I don't
under definitely hit once he doesn't
mind bringing the other rook into the
game if white loses this strong dark
square Bishop because this dark square
bishop could be pretty useful later on
maybe if if it could somehow get the g3
without black being able to push at 4 it
will be very useful on this diagonal so
I don't actually wants to get rid of
this Bishop and Jones goes for this we
have Bishop captures rook captures and
now Queen to d3 and what do you play
here I mean Queen to d3 of course is a
move but still this see characters on d4
is never possible for example here if
you play C captures on d4 this is just
losing again you get Bishop captures
Queen captures but now after Knight
captures attacking the Queen and the
bishop let's say you move the Queen to
protect it now Knight captures and this
also opens up the attack from the bishop
to the rook the knight is also attacking
both works so you don't have a time to
actually trade Queens and then move one
of the rooks or something so you
probably have to capture it and then you
simply lose a rook and at the end of at
the end of all of this you're simply
down a piece so after this row captures
on the 8th Jones goes for Queen to d3 we
have Queen to f4 and here again what do
you play here probably you want to
develop some pieces but the question is
how probably a move like night to a3 you
know just develop that piece connect
your rooks to do something again it's
it's very hard to decide a move here for
white you could maybe try seek after
some before now but it really doesn't
change things now after seek after some
before you get Knight captures and now
after Knight captures Bishop captures
now the rock and a1 is attacked and also
not there's an attack from the bishop
and the Queen to the f2 phone you can
stop this with Queen to d2 offer a trade
of Queens also protect f2 but now simply
Queen to h4 your
rook is still attacked the only way to
defend it is Knight to c3 but now comes
Knight it captures and c4 attacking the
Queen and now the Queen has to move from
the protection of the F to square after
the Queen moves and now simply Bishop
captures King moves and now comes the
finishing blow this is actually a pretty
good diagram feel free to pause the
video here although it's a sideline find
the finishing blow here after this move
there is no defense it's actually a
force to checkmate in six moves but the
movies you know quite quite nice okay
for those of you who found it
congratulations even though it is a
signed line the move is Bishop to f3 and
after this move there is no defense
there is nothing white can play Queen
captures on h3 checkmate is coming as
the pawn and g2 is pinned you can
capture the bishop Queen captures on h3
is again checkmate so this would this
would lead to a very very sharp line
that would end in Y being checkmated so
after this Queen to f4 move white does
have to find a move and this reminds me
of an old chest saying that the most
beautiful moves in chests are never
actually played so if you're not a if
you're not an excellent player you don't
know why certain moves are played you
don't see the beauty of the game even
though sometimes hard positional games
appear boring they are boring because
the very strong players are playing them
so they avoid any any harsh
complications
so here Jones played Queen to d2
offering a trade of Queens and aren't
immediately accepts this Queen captures
on b2 and Knight capture sandy to
another doesn't care that his down the
exchange because he has a beautiful
bishop here okay this is still a fourth
line but let's finish the line here D
captures on c3 forcing the knight to
move away from the protection of the f3
Knight Knight to b3 and now Bishop
captures G captures and now comes
Knights to be for attacking the bishop
and c2 and if you look at this position
Anand has a beautiful night on before
making white worry about that Bishop and
c2 this night is coming to c-4 with
capturing upon this rook is awesome on
the
the open defiled this bishop is
extremely strong and g7 it will be even
stronger when it comes to h6 and not
allowing any rope to c1 to defend the
bishop so so you know it's not only that
Anand has compensation he's actually
much better here you know to play this
with white you have to play it like
super precise but for human deaths it's
easier said than done
so rook to e2 we have Knight captures on
c4 now
Anand Knights came from b6 and c6 the b4
and c4
I saw someone posted a tweet on Twitter
saying that
Anand uses his teleporting Knights trick
to avoid the traffic in Chennai so this
is definitely what he meant so rock 2 c1
and now comes b5 there were a lot of
moves here Bishop to h6 immediately a
lot of ideas here for what for black
since black definitely has a better
position but iron goes for b5 he wants
to start pushing his Queen side pawns to
add some more pressure to the Queen side
and this will be this will be impossible
to stop
we have night 2 a1 and this night Tory
one comes with the idea that now the
night is protecting the bishop and c2
and now the rooks will be able to move
and maybe cause some trouble for Anand
but again that's easier said than done
Bishop to h6 we have worked to be one
attacking the knight and now a5
kingi to Knight to e2 attacking the rook
and now rook to e1 we have Bishop to F
force not allowing King any escape the
White King has to stay here and also the
now the bishop has a lot of options here
he can either protect the Queen Square
here if necessary he can go back to
defend Bishop c7 Bishop d6 not allow any
rook to e7 infiltration but since Jones
immediately goes for rook to e7
attacking the h7 point on plays rook to
d7
we have rook e8 check King c7 and now
rook to e8
attacking the f5 pawn we have a 5 a kink
the b6 is also an idea here but a5 is
just as good rope to e6 and
here we have kink the b7 forcing that
rook to choose where it wants to go
whether it will go to a five although
after up d5 the rook will be very
passive there on a5 so Jones goes for
rook 88 and here it's it's you know it's
a brilliant position for black on and
you can simply capture the a to phone
the Knights captures an 82 and so
perfectly fine position postpone those
pawns are now ready to be pushed but
iron goes for the human-like move he
plays Bishop to d6 and what's the idea
of Bishop to d6 well it simply stops any
white ideas Jones could good try before
the bishop came to d6 something like
rook to e7 and then maybe exchanged one
rook and then the other roof can maybe
pick up those kings at pawns but after
Bishop to d6 both works on e-file or
simply useless so we have Bishop to d1
and now Knight to d5 the thread is of
course Knight to f4 check for King the
king and the rook on e6 so rook goes
back to here Knight to f4 check King to
h1 and now Bishop to c5 opening up this
rooks influence and the D file also may
be attacking the f2 pawn
we have Bishop to e2 and now comes
Knight captures rook captures and before
and after this before move was played
this is move 40 no this is move 39 but
after this move they will reach move 40
they will reach time control and it's
actually in this position that going
Jones resigned at the game there is
nothing he can do here now the material
is basically equal as done now does have
two pawns for the exchange so I mean
there is no move here white can make and
even if you look at the pawn structure
they're just terrible these pawns here
three point islands they're just
pathetic really
b3 is coming this can be stopped and
there's there's nothing
Jones can do here so that's the game I
think this win places on and again
insured first spot with on you
and I just saw that Mama dr1 his game
against Peter Svidler it was a very very
feisty game although the sweedler did
mess up in the opening it's really
masterful how my media of handled that
position so I believe mama dro is now
also insured first place and we'll see
what Carlsen will do against Wesley so a
dead game still isn't over and Crossan
is really really trying to show Wesley
who's boss it's a pretty equal position
but Carlson is really milking it hard so
yeah that's that's the follow up on the
tournament that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jonas
Paul Hart Rodrigo Carvalho and Alan
brown for a contribution to my channel
and also an unknown person for a
contribution in light point I would
really appreciate it if you since I
can't know who contributed via like on
or bit point I would really appreciate
it if you just send me an email so I can
thank you properly in the video so yeah
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon definitely with
another game from the tata steel chess
tournament